So love is blind is getting sued again.
Netflix is coming under heat by a former cast member
because she was engaged on the show.
Her story was never really told,
but apparently
the person that she married, uh,
turned out to be,
uh, homeless
and had a drug addiction,
and she's suing Netflix.
But what is interesting is that the contract
that she signed as a cast member
is now out in the public domain
because of that lawsuit she filed.
So I took a look at the contract
and found a couple interesting things
that I wanted to share with you guys.
One of them is that they actually
are not allowed to file for divorce
within the first 11 months of getting married.
So the fact that these marriages last,
whatever amount they do last,
is a little bit of a,
uh, red herring,
because they can't divorce before that period.
That's contractually binding.
And another thing that's kind of interesting
is that they have to agree that the
network is not responsible
for any pregnancies that occur during or after filming.
So the network is not responsible for the cost
or any liability or claims,
anything goes wrong.
And another interesting clause they had in there
was that the, uh,
participants have to agree that
for whatever period of time that the network decides
before they get married
that they go no contact and can't see each other,
that's up to the network's discretion.
And they Have to agree not to speak or see
their partner right before the wedding.
So who knows how long that time period could be
where they're not allowed to see each other
or talk to each other
and still have to go through with the wedding
and show up.
Um. Before making their final decisions.
So I'll keep you guys posted with what else I find
in this contract,
cause I'm sure there's a lot of interesting tidbits.